why
so like our video on spider-man we're
not going to be going in depth into the
entire event involving hold versus
Ironman and there's a couple reasons for
this the first reason is simply just
time the hall versus Iron Man story is
for parts and for the most part up until
issue number four all we really see is
this kind of cat-and-mouse game with the
Incredible Hulk is chasing after Iron
Man and both individuals are trying to
unlock or trying to discover what it was
that it truly happened and all these
different things taking place but the
other half of this is that we are
wanting to move forward past original
sin and into Infinity Gauntlet and so in
order to ensure that this happens we're
going to go ahead and jump a little bit
when it comes to the Incredible Hulk vs
Iron Man story now if you're curious
with the back story if you're interested
in knowing the kind of things that went
on and what the relationship was like
between Bruce Banner and The Incredible
re and Tony Stark then comic story and
Benny has a really good video up where
he covers a lot of this backstory stuff
but what we need to do before we get
into the original sin' revelation is we
need to jump back to May of 1962 and we
need to go over the Incredible Hulk
issue number one and Marvel's revelation
to us to how it is that Bruce Banner
became the Incredible Hulk and what we
learn here is that Bruce Banner along
with a colleague named Igor is looking
to set off or to detonate something
called the gamma bomb now the gamma bomb
was supposed to be the next step in the
weapons arsenal of the United States it
was supposed to be a bomb that was
designed to have such a high yield such
a high magnitude that were it would in
effect just scare people off people just
wouldn't want to confront the United
States because of the kind of weaponry
that's being developed here in addition
we see that a teenage kid some young kid
was able to make his way into the
testing area where the bomb is supposed
to detonate and that if this bomb goes
off while that kid is there then the kid
will be killed and so in an effort to to
ensure safety all around Bruce Banner
races off to try to rescue this young
teenage kid and try to get him out of
the dangers
but what we see here is that his
colleague Igor is actually a Russian in
disguise and he's a spy for the Russian
government and so what he rationalizes
here is that he can kill Bruce Banner by
setting off the bomb prematurely and
that when Bruce Banner is in the testing
area Bruce Banner will be totally
eradicated and Igor will be the only
other person who is aware of what's
going on and how to use this gamma bomb
technology that Bruce Banner has
developed over the years from here we
switch to the testing area and as we can
see this young kid just seems to be
sitting here playing a harmonica just
sort of hanging out and and chilling and
whatnot but what we see is that while
Bruce Banner grabs this young man and
throws him into a trench
Igor presses the fire button and the
expectation here is that this bomb is
going to kill Bruce Banner but instead
what we see is that Bruce banners body
is saturated with gamma rays his entire
being is completely filled with it and
so he survives but of course we learned
that later on this leads to him becoming
the Incredible Hulk now from here we
switch to original sin issue number four
and what we learn here is that where
previously it was assumed that maybe
that the the bomb going off at Igor's
involvement was a cause of Bruce Banner
becoming the Incredible Hulk that while
that was the catalyst that was the
actual action that led to it now there's
actually more to this story and what we
learn is that Tony Stark and Bruce
Banner were actually colleagues at one
point in time they had worked together
but the way the Marvel has explained the
fact that nobody seems to remember this
is actually a little disappointing
Marvel simply just chalks this up to
Tony Stark's alcoholism and just says
that you know because Tony's talk was an
alcohol alcoholic because he has blank
patches in his mind they just doesn't
remember it which if I give you a little
Frank here I think is sort of lazy
writing but what we had seen previously
is that general Thunderbolt Ross who of
course Bruce Banner had approached with
regards to the gamma bomb gamma bomb
project had enlisted the aid of Tony
Stark to investigate the shielding due
to an argument that Tony Stark and Bruce
Banner had we're
by Tony Stark said that Bruce Banner was
holding back the capabilities of the
bomb by shielding the explosion and so
what we see is that general Thunderbolt
Ross has tasked Tony Stark with
investigating the shielding to seeing if
maybe this is true to seeing if there's
a way to get the most bang for their
buck so to speak to make the bomb as
potent as possible while still allowing
it to still be controllable and so what
we see is that Tony Stark is he's
continuing to investigate this bomb
begins to talk to us about how if just
one of these pieces went bad if just one
of these pieces were missing it could
set up a chain reaction that would be
added absolutely catastrophic and
initially the way he explains it to us
he's kind of arguing with himself that
maybe in his drunken state he's
considering allowing this to happen he's
considering maybe removing one of these
pieces and allowing Bruce banners bomb
to screw up and possibly Bruce Banner
being either discredited or maybe even
killed in the process what we see that
Tony Stark rationalizes with himself
that Bruce banners his friend and that
while he may not like him very much
that he doesn't need to take the road of
effectively murdering him we also see
that again this the alcoholism of Tony
Stark coming into play when he says he
doesn't care for himself too much either
but that's no reason to take out this on
on Bruce Banner what we also see is that
Tony Stark while he's continuing to
investigate the bomb comes to the
realization that the shielding that's
been placed over the bomb will actually
do the opposite of what Bruce Banner is
expecting that the shielding is going to
cause the bomb to explode on a much
higher scale instead of confining the
explosion of the bomb and so try to
think of this in terms of the damage
that could be done if you had a maybe a
grenade that you set on top of a table
and you allow the grenade to go off the
grenade would be very destructive it
would destroy a lot of different things
but if you wrapped a grenade in sheet
metal and then you allow the grenade to
go off the destruction would be even
worse and so what we see is Tony Stark
rationalizing that this is the case that
because there is too much shielding the
bomb is going to be far more destructive
than anybody thinks it is and so we see
that he begins to go through the process
of modifying the gamma bomb and
we modifies it in such a way to where he
removed some of the shielding so that
the explosion the destruction won't be
nearly as bad we also see him in a
little bit of a comedic way talking
about how while Bruce Banner is a
pacifist that he's able to take out are
able to make one heck of a bomb but we
also see Tony Stark again arguing with
himself in debating as to whether or not
he's actually going to tell Bruce Banner
that he's made these modifications and
that these modifications will keep Bruce
Banner safe that it will keep the
observers along with Bruce Banner from
being killed in the explosion from here
we transition back to Bruce Banner and
II and Tony Stark as the two of them are
having a conversation out in the desert
which of course is where we had picked
up before we had gotten into our
discussion on the original sin memories
but what we see here is that while Bruce
Banner in the incredibly I'm sorry Bruce
Banner and Tony stocker talking Bruce
Banner is is satisfied with his
explanation Bruce Banner doesn't realize
at least as far from far as he can tell
that Tony Stark had basically saved his
life and saved the lives of various
observers which include Betty Ross and
so we see that for the most part Bruce
Banner who was initially angry with Tony
Stark is now calmed down he now feels
like it's really his fault that he was
that he became the Incredible Hulk that
is not actually the fault of Tony Stark
but what we learn as Bruce Banner begins
to leave is that Tony Stark didn't tell
him everything that not everything
involving the the events of Bruce Banner
becoming the Incredible Hulk were
explained by Tony Stark to him and what
we see is that Tony Stark is in a
drunken state on his bed and he's
mulling over what he's going to say to
to Bruce Banner he activates the voice
dictation system and he begins to
effectively just speak what it is that
he wants to say in an email and what he
tells Bruce Banner is that he's fixed
his bomb that he has enabled the bomb to
to detonate the way it's expected to by
removing some of the shielding in
addition the part that is most poignant
here the part that is the most important
here
is Bruce Banner I'm sorry uh tony
stark's revelation of the fact that he
was aware that the possibility existed
that the saturation of gamma rays into
the cells of an organism could very well
transform that organism and this is what
he tells Bruce Banner he tells Bruce
Banner that he looked at the energy
emission spectrum and that there was all
kinds of crazy things in there and that
he he knows some individuals who have
worked with morphogenic technology and
that most likely the gamma ray explosion
will cause a I guess a a change in the
bio matter will causing the change a
caused a change in the cells of
whichever organism is exposed to that
much gamma radiation at one point in
time now this doesn't mean that Tony
Stark knows that Bruce Banner is going
to become the Incredible Hulk or that if
he was exposed to the gamma rays that he
would become the Incredible Hulk
it's simply Tony Stark telling Bruce
Banner that exposure to the gamma rays
would cause some kind of cell mutation
would cause something to happen within
the body that could have an adverse
effect or could have a beneficial effect
and so he asked Bruce Banner to take a
second look to to take a look before he
sets off the gamma bomb but what we see
is that when Bruce Banner arrives at his
lab the next day to analyze the gamma
bomb to go over his his findings and
studies that he sees the email from Tony
Stark but that he promptly deletes it
without ever looking at it to see what
it is from here we see Tony Stark kind
of again talking to us or talking to
himself telling us that he knows that
after he said that email that Bruce
Banner didn't look at it and the reason
why he didn't look at it is because
Bruce Banner is the Incredible Hulk and
that it would drive Bruce Banner insane
if he was informed that the only reason
why he became the Incredible Hulk is
because he didn't check an email that he
was so much like Tony Stark in the sense
that he was being so proud but from here
we're going to bring the tie-ins to an
end we're not going to discuss any more
tie-ins here just because for the most
part again we want to continue on with
the original sin storyline and
eventually move forward into Infinity
Gauntlet so with that being said I'm
gonna go ahead bring this video to an
end hope you guys enjoyed it if you did
let me know and I will catch you guys
later
peace
you